sara martini faces up to 25 years in
prison for helping other refugees on the
Greek island of Lesbos I would do it all
over again
for the rest of my life it's
transferring me from being a refugee to
a rescuer she says she was volunteering
with the rescue team in Greece on our
way back to Germany she was arrested and
charged with crimes including people
smuggling money laundering and espionage
Amnesty International criticizes the
case as an attempt to criminalize
humanitarian work in a climate that is
increasingly hostile towards migrants
and refugees it was very shocking
training I was disappointing and
heartbroken because I was ready to leave
I was looking forward to study again and
did someone just take everything from
you like one seconds
Sarah spent one hundred and seven days
in pretrial detention and was released
on bail she then returned to her College
in Berlin I knew inside that I've done
that because I wanted to help people and
that's giving motivation I didn't do
anything illegal because I didn't
contact anyone directly again I wasn't
just in the shoreline and our house a
year Stephan and she was just a no-show
and I'm just handing water and blanket
you think I need water and blanket is
illegal no it's not but people say that
because they know there's someone
waiting mm-hmm that's why they come if
there was no I don't believe though
because when I crossed there was no one
wedding and I made it and I knew there's
no one waiting in 2015 Sarah and her
sister yousra
first made headlines in 2015 after
fleeing Syria they used their swimming
skills to pull their boat to shore on
its journey from Turkey to lesbos they
saved themselves and 18 other people
you Sura is now a UNHCR goodwill
ambassador and was on the refugee team
at the Rio 2016 Olympics Sarah won a
scholarship to study social sciences in
Berlin but kept returning to lesbos and
joined the Greek NGO that assists newly
arrived refugees I believe when you fear
something just go for it so I fear the
place that I landed in and I wanted to
be on this ground again following her
arrest in August 2000 18 Sara's
classmates campaign for a release
extremely relieved it was just a
beautiful moment to be able to walk over
to our cafeteria with Sarah knowing that
everybody was going to be waiting there
but Greek authorities claim Sarah was
part of a criminal network
she is currently awaiting trial this
experience in general just give me this
dramatizing fear and and I'm afraid that
I'm not gonna get my feedback because
even if I'm outside but I'm see on the
trial and I still can that go to the
place that I love